well a lot of depressing stuff going on
in the world but something
non-depressing happened on planet earth
yesterday which was kind of
cool there was already cool stuff
happening in space but now
something cool happened on planet earth
according to the new york times the
first astronaut trip to orbit by a
private company parachuted to a safe
conclusion in the gulf of mexico on
sunday
it was the first water landing by nasa
astronauts since 1975
when the agency's crews were still
flying to and from orbit and the apollo
modules used for the historic american
moon missions
riding in a capsule built and operated
by spacex the rocket company founded by
elon musk
two nasa astronauts robert behnken and
douglas hurley splashed down near
pensacola florida on sunday afternoon
the crew dragon capsule suspended under
four giant billowing orange and white
parachutes
saddled upright into the water at a
gentle pace of 15 miles per hour at 2 48
p.m
eastern time michael hyman the spacex
engineer communicating with astronauts
said on behalf of the spacex and nasa
teams welcome back to planet earth and
thanks
for flying spacex it took me an hour to
uh to go pick them up from the water
although nasa was the customer this time
the mission could be a first step to
more people going to space for a variety
of new activities like sightseeing
corporate research and satellite repair
the goal of the space agency is to turn
over to private enterprise
some things it used to do joining us on
the line to discuss is nasa
administrator jim bradenstein
administrator bradenstein appreciate
your time let me ask you what do you see
as the future of the cooperation between
public and private when it comes to nasa
obviously
spacex has plans outside of what it does
with the us government but what do you
see as sort of the future of cooperation
here
yeah so you know the history the history
is nasa used to
purchase own and operate its own
vehicles and
and the way we want to go in the future
is we want to enter into these
public-private partnerships
uh where where in fact nasa can become a
customer we want to be
one customer of many customers in a very
robust commercial marketplace in low
earth orbit
but we also want to have numerous
providers that compete against each
other
on cost and innovation and safety
creating a virtuous cycle
of continuous innovation for more access
to space than ever before
we've now done that with commercial
resupply
to the international space station we've
now done it with commercial crew
to the international space station and
the next step is commercial space
stations themselves
ultimately that's the direction that we
need to get because then we can use the
resources that we have to do things
for which there's not yet a commercial
marketplace things like
go to the moon sustainably and go to
mars and
and of course every step along the way
we're always thinking about
how do we commercialize look if the
government is is the only institution
providing the resources
then it is a zero-sum game and we will
never progress the way
we need to progress what we need to do
is we need to enable the commercial
sector to come along
find customers that are not nasa and
then we need to move further and do more
than we've ever
been able to do before what do you see
as the timeline for
something as ambitious as building a
base on the moon or getting to mars
so we're going to do our first mission
with humans to the moon in 2024 and
we're not just landing the next man
we're landing the first woman
and that's on the agenda of the
president of the united states
um i think we can we can be sustainable
on the moon by 2028
but we will have our our next humans on
the moon by 2024. when i say sustainable
what i don't mean is a permanent human
presence what i mean is
we're able to have access to any part of
the moon any time we want
which of course is critically important
for a whole host of reasons that go
beyond
just research but also it's it is very
important for research and discovery and
exploration
but more than anything ben what we need
to learn how to do is we need to learn
how to live and work on another world
for long periods of time
using the resources of that other world
in other words the moon
so we have to use the hundreds of
millions of tons of water ice
on the south pole of the moon water ice
represents air to breathe
and water to drink but it's also
hydrogen hydrogen of course is the same
rocket fuel
that powered the space shuttles it's
available in hundreds of millions of
tons
on the moon and then we need to take
that knowledge for how to be sustainable
sustainable on the moon we need to take
that knowledge on to mars
the challenge with mars ben is that mars
and earth are on the same side of the
sun
once every 26 months when we go to mars
we have to be willing to stay and the
president has said we're going to put an
american flag on mars
and that's what we intend to do as a
sci-fi fan there are all sorts of
theories about how we balance private
corporate needs and
and business with governmental influence
how do you see that balance playing out
as we explore new worlds
yeah so right now on the international
space station we are
make no mistake it is there because of
taxpayer investment make no mistake
but also we have to think about what are
we doing on the international space
station
that enables the taxpayer to remove
itself over time from that solution set
so right now we're looking at advanced
materials
uh things like z bland would think of
very pristine fiber optic networks
um that that you know actually you don't
have to have cable repeaters every
quarter of a mile
they're so pristine that it you know it
really changes the business case and
drives down the cost
of laying fiber in a city for example um
we're creating with artificial materials
um you know materials that are so thin
they're one atom thick what does that
mean that means we can create things
like
an artificial retina for the human
eyeball so that people who have macular
degeneration
don't have to go blind but instead
they'll be able to continue to see
we're also looking at you know
industrial biomedicines things like
the ability to use adult stem cells your
own skin cells for example
to create your own human tissue for
regenerative medicine for
you know eventually being able to create
your own organs out of your own
adult stem cells and we can only do that
in the microgravity of space
because of the value that microgravity
has if you try to do that in the gravity
well of earth
the tissue would just go flat but
there's so much more we're talking about
compounding pharmaceuticals in
microgravity and
creating immunizations for things like
salmonella and pneumonia in space things
that you can't do
on the earth so um but the goal here is
to prove on the international space
station
that we can commercialize these things
then we allow private capital to flow
and finance ultimately what will
eventually be uh continuous human
habitation and low earth orbit for the
duration
then nasa of course can go on to the
moon always thinking about
what are the what are the commercial
benefits but this is so important for
your audience right now you and i are
talking
uh via satellite um we think about all
the things that nasa has contributed to
society over time
directv dish network internet broadband
from space i come from oklahoma
a lot of rural oklahomans would not have
internet if it wasn't for internet
broadband from space
xm radio for example but also the way we
navigate with gps the way we produce
food we're increasing crop yields
reducing water usage the way we
produce energy in a very clean way the
way we predict weather the way we
understand climate the way we do
national security and disaster relief
so many of these benefits um are born
from this little agency called nasa
that are so important um that we can't
dismiss
that this this is an investment by the
american taxpayer our goal is to always
commercialize but we cannot dismiss
all of the wonderful things that have
come from these programs and perhaps you
can talk for a second about the sort of
cost savings that are available
because of the use of a private
enterprise in situations like this
yeah absolutely so when we think about
the space shuttles it was a they were
absolutely magnificent
instruments of engineering uh marvels of
technology but also very very expensive
and and and the government would just
purchase own and operate them which of
course
guaranteed that they would stay very
very expensive
with the new model again what we're
looking for is we want to
we want to do development with a
commercial partner
once it is developed we want to step
back and we want to buy
you know we want to buy a rocket every
time we need one or we want to buy a
seat
to space every time we need one but we
expect
those those those providers to go get
customers that are not nasa
and if they're willing to do that our
costs go down and
the benefits to humanity go way up
because there's far more capital
outside of nasa than there is inside of
nasa
so these partnerships really do drive
down the cost you know i want to also be
clear
you know we haven't had a human space
flight program from american soil
since 2011 which was when the last space
shuttle retired
so we've been nine years without a human
space flight program
since then we've been we've been buying
seats on russian soyuz rockets
at the tune of about 90 million dollars
per seat at this point
um and now we're going to be buying
seats at closer to 50 million dollars
per seat
so it's an american capability the the
money goes to the united states of
america
and and of course the cost is far less
than it would be if we were buying from
russia
well thank you so much administrator
bradenstein congratulations
thank you so much
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content